[Music]
what's going on guys
transformers the last night the fifth
Transformers film is hitting theaters
next week and even though they're not
what I would call intricately plotted
it's still nice to know what you're
getting into so here is a rundown of the
first four live-action Transformers
films which I watched over one long
crazy weekend first up the original
transformers a long time ago there was a
civil war transformers home planet of
Cybertron over control of the Allspark a
cube that gives transformers life
Cybertron was in ruins and the cube
ended up lost on earth where Megatron
the Decepticon leader ended up frozen
after crash landing in the Arctic Circle
thousands of years later Megatron is
discovered by an explorer who
accidentally activates his navigational
system which imprints the coordinates of
the Allspark on his glasses don't worry
about it cut two decades later where we
meet the great great grandson of that
explorer Sam Witwicky played by Shia
LaBeouf hey both of those names are fun
to say turns out those pesky Autobots
are still trying to find Megatron and
the Allspark making life really tough
for soldiers like Josh Duhamel hey
another fun name to say Sam's dad takes
him to buy his first car so he can
impress Mikaela a girl who is so far out
of his league it's distracting but don't
assume she's just a pretty face I think
there's a lot more than meets the eye
you that's the catchphrase as it turns
out Sam's new car is also more than
meets the eye
it's bumblebee I bought a car
turned out to be an alien robot the
Decepticons realized Sam's great great
Grandpa's glasses are the key to finding
the cube and chase after him but
bumblebee saves them and undergoes a
makeover slash marketing ploy and we
finally meet Optimus Prime and the rest
of the Autobot both Jazz's name and
voice are problematic
whispering biggest optimus reveals that
the Decepticons want to use the Allspark
to wipe out all of Earth's humans secret
government agency sector seven shows up
led by agent Simmons and they capture
Sam Michaela and bumblebee they know
about the Transformers but are total
dicks not realizing there are good
robots and bad robots also I don't want
to gloss over this acclaimed actor John
Turturro gets peed on by a transformer
the first in an escalating series of
humiliations for that man in this
franchise sector seven gathers up all
the movie's main characters and brings
them to the hoover dam which turns out
to be an elaborate cover to hide one of
Uncle Sam's biggest secrets a still
frozen Megatron and the Allspark
meanwhile Optimus Prime finds the
glasses and leads the Autobots towards
the Allspark but uh-oh a sneaky
Decepticon follows them and unfreezes
Megatron
bubbly makes the allspark small and then
for some reason it's given to the two
least qualified people in the group to
protect them finally almost two hours
into the movie the Transformers all
fights
there's tons of explosions and
transformer on transformer crunching
lots of famous brands get turned into
Decepticons Optimus says the cube can be
destroyed by putting it in his chest but
it will kill him being a spunky hero
that he is Sam puts the Kuban Megatron's
chest instead which destroys both
Megatron and the Allspark meaning that
the thing that Megatron wanted more than
anything in the world was the thing that
would kill him instantly which makes no
sense but whatever it's transformers
movie guys moving on to one of the worst
sequels of all time Transformers Revenge
of the Fallen two years after the first
movie the Autobots and the army have
formed a secret task force called nest
two for what remains about Decepticons
close they kick out a Decepticon who
uses his last breath to tell them okay
well it turns out the Fallen is a super
old evil transformer who tried to
destroy the Sun to harvest Energon which
is like transformer gas but he would
stop by ancient good-guy transformers
who sacrificed themselves to hide his
Sun Harvester which is activated with
the matrix of leadership again don't
worry about it meanwhile Sam's going to
college while Mikaela stays behind to
sexually assault motorcycles on his way
out
Sam touches a piece of the Allspark that
was somehow lost in his clothes for two
years after his kitchen tries to kill
him
sam says epic leaves the shard with
Megan Fox and goes to college
Sam moves into his dorm and Sam's mom
gets high in a low point for both her
and for comedy in general
thank you faster I'd do anything for an
a that night Sam goes to Michael Bay's
idea of a frat party spazzes out and
sees the transformer language which
makes them act super derpy I go on a
signal you wanted for the formula for
interdimensional energy accretion
National Security Adviser and total
buzzkill Galloway wants to kick the
Autobots off earth because he doesn't
want to be stuck in the middle of their
transformer war the Decepticon Soundwave
eavesdrops on their conversation to find
out the location of the other last
remaining shard of the Allspark which
they can use to revive Megatron and take
over the world so far same plot as the
first movie except now instead of
killing Megatron the Allspark will bring
him back to life oh that's how that
works
Megatron has revived and he flies to
Saturn hey it's that mean transformer
from the beginning the Fallen turns out
he's Megatron's mentor who reveals that
Sam has absorbed the power of the
Allspark that's why you see in their
language now only he can lead the
Decepticons to their Energon Harvester
just saving our race now die within jeez
bye
Mikaela captures a spy Decepticon trying
to steal the Allspark shard that Sam
gave her she takes it to Sam but walks
in on him making out with a hot blonde
only it's not a real hot lon
it's a Decepticon now that's a disguise
a very michaelbay light disguise Mikaela
Sam and Sam's roommate are captured by
Megatron who probes Sam for the code to
find the Energon but the Autobots show
up in the nick of time to fight and
super slo-mo and rescue everyone except
Megatron kills Optimus Oh No
and even worse Sam in the audience are
now stuck with mudflap and skids
remember what I said about jazz earlier
double it why don't you get a haircut
League you'll get chance the Fallen
leads an invasion of Earth they capture
Sam's parents and send out a message to
the world unless you turn over
this coin Sam tries to decode the
symbols with the help of Simmons who now
runs a deli and continues to be an
embarrassment to John Turturro's career
they find an old transformer in the
Smithsonian Air and Space Museum named
Jetfire who they bring back to life with
sam's Allspark shard
Jetfire teleports everyone to Egypt and
explains more backstory about the fallen
the Sun Harvester and the massive amount
of trouble at the planet event oh and
one more thing
oh he primed you defeat the cold him so
now Sam has to find the matrix of
leadership to bring Optimus Prime back
to life so he can defeat the Fallen but
won't that destroy the Sun now whatever
look how great Megan Fox looks up
Michael Bay you are priceless they find
the hiding place of the matrix of
leadership but when Sam touches it it
turns to toast what time is it it's
robot fighting time it turns out that
the Energon harvesting machine is under
the pyramids yeah where else would it be
there's a lot of fighting a bunch of
Constructicons form a transformer
Voltron a bulldozer spits out Sam's
parents
there's tanks on hover craft Sam and
Mikaela run in slow motion while there
are lots and lots of explosions and
countless priceless Egyptian historical
landmarks are destroyed Sam dies and
goes to transformer heaven for some
reason where he learns that the matrix
has to be earned and bam the dust turns
back into the key the real matrix was
inside Sam all along he activates
Optimus just as the Fallen shows up and
Prime goes ham and destroys the Sun
harvesting machine and the Fallen oh and
Megatron he runs away like a punk and
then as one does Optimus and Sam ride an
aircraft carrier into the sunset
moving on to movie number three
Transformers Dark of the Moon which I
can't stop calling Dark Side of the Moon
I guess I listen to too much pink
floyd-- anyway we start with a
derivative Star Wars like space battle
between autobots and decepticons
sentinel prime who's like optimus but
older crashes his ship the arc
on the moon through terrible JFK CGI we
learned that the moon mission was really
a ploy to find transformers we're now in
the present day where we follow a butt
up the stairs
it's rosie huntington Wheatley aka Carly
Spencer our hero's Sam Witwicky keys new
girlfriend Megan Fox got fired from the
series for calling Michael Bay Fiddler's
true story Sam can't find a job despite
getting a medal from CGI Obama and ends
up working for John Malkovich Optimus
Prime finds a piece of the Ark in of
course Chernobyl and heads to the moon
where he finds the ship and his old
buddy Sentinel Prime the ship has
technology called a space bridge
controlled by a bunch of pillars aka
MacGuffins which can be used to
transport Cybertron to earth Megatron
and friends want that technology optimus
revives Sentinel Prime the Einstein of
the Transformers he seems like a pretty
chill dude until double-cross he reveals
he made a deal with Megatron to destroy
the earth and bring back Cybertron
Turturro is re-enlisted by Sam because
two churros got to eat we learned that
his girlfriend's boss McDreamy
is a bad dude and he's working for the
enemy
what a traitor kidnapped Sam's
girlfriend Sentinel Prime tricks the
government into exiling all the Autobots
so the Decepticons will leave - then
their spaceship explodes that's it folks
end of the series so long adios roll
credits just kidding there's a lot more
movie left Sentinel Prime takes over
Chicago to start bringing Cybertron to
Earth and McDreamy holds up in the Trump
Tower because of course can we try to
redirect them to a Trump Tower and new
Trump was working with the Decepticons
when all hope seems lost Optimus Prime
returns to say you thought we were gone
JK lol we were just playing no it's like
we ain't goin nowhere there are
explosions dudes and wingsuits tyrese ah
no one gets seriously injured despite
sliding down all sorts of broken glass
and getting tossed around like a rag
doll
bumblebee destroys the most important
magic space filler warding this weird
terraforming type plot then Prime and
Sentinel gots to throw down ones friends
now foes Sam's girlfriend lectures
Megatron and uses grade school reverse
psychology to turn him against Sentinel
- thank you [ __ ]
Optimus and Megatron defeat Sentinel
together and then Optimus performs a mob
style execution on bold oh stop
cold-blooded
and finally Sam and his girlfriend kiss
and the world is saved again there's one
more movie transformers age of
extinction well we finally found out
what killed the dinosaurs of course it
was an alien race called creators who
used devices called seeds to terraform
earth and cover in a metal called
transform 'i'm catchy trademarked that
is the least creative element name since
unobtainium anyway turns out they're
metal dinosaurs buried in the ground
moving on we travel to a Shia LeBoeuf
list present-day where the government
led by Frasier Crane has had enough of
these Robot Wars and is hunting and
killing all transformers with the help
of their bounty hunter lock down deep in
the heart of America we meet Texan cave
Yeager amateur inventor I'm an inventor
and single father - Tessa he and TJ
Miller find a semi in an old building
that they can strip for parts but guess
what I don't think it's a truck at all
I think we just found a transformer yep
it's Optimus Prime and he's in bad shape
looks like you better check the CARFAX
Cade works on reviving Optimus but uh-oh
TJ Miller snitches on them to the
government Optimus makes a break for it
and Tess's race car driver boyfriend
Shane shows up to rescue everyone after
a long chase they get away but not
before TJ Miller is killed by lockdown
r.i.p comic relief optimus gets sexy and
drives through the desert summoning the
remaining Autobots who are all
conveniently nearby they even have a new
culturally and appropriate transformer
finding a combat using a CIA drone Cade
discovers the government is in cahoots
with an evil corporation called ksi to
hunt and kill all transformers Cade
agrees to help the Autobots but not
before his daughter's boyfriend shows
him a card that proves why it's okay for
him to bang his underage daughter why
didn't they just make her a year older
instead of putting in that weird creepy
scene we meet Joshua Joyce the douchey
CEO of ksi who's played by the 2ch
stanley tucci with Frasier cranes help
ksi is harvesting transform 'i'm from
dead transformers now we can change
anything into anything except this into
a good movie seriously that pill product
placement is literally the worst to make
matters worse ksi has Megatron's head
for research and they're building their
own transformers and we fill them
brother the Autobots flip out and attack
the lab but Joyce hurts their feelings
and they leave don't you get it
we don't need you ksi activates their
transformers to attack the Autobots but
they're glitchy and they kill a lot of
innocent civilians lockdown shows up and
captures Optimus and your creators wants
you back
Tessa is stuck with them and they both
get taken aboard lockdowns creepy ship
full of various transformer and alien
prisoners lockdowns deal with the
government is fulfilled and he gives
them one of those super bad world
destroying seeds when primus come seek
aid Shan and the Autobots sneak aboard
the ship to rescue Tessa and that
transformer smoking a cigar okay I can't
even with this on the ship
lockdown releases the Robo wolves and
Kade finds a sword gun and then they
make a daring escape in Chicago again
poor Chicago they can't catch a break
from these killer robots
Megatron's intelligence merges with the
evil ksi transformer Galvatron to become
Megatron 2.0 he wants the seed for
himself so he can build a massive army
and naya late your species forever
Galvatron goes rogue and frees all the
other ksi transformers to do his bidding
Jois escapes with the seed and heads to
transformer age of extinction
co-financier China and all hell breaks
loose Cave kills the guy from lost with
a football Optimus frees a bunch of
dinosaur transformers aka
Dinobots and rides them into battle now
I can't tell if this is badass or total
nonsense but Wahlberg's into it the auto
slash Dinobots
kill all of the ksi transformers but
because the studio agreed to a two-hour
40 minute runtime for this mess lockdown
comes back to capture Optimus his giant
ship starts destroying the city with his
super advanced alien technology
it's a big magnet it's coming
the Autobots get the seed out of the
city while Optimus fights lockdown Kaede
goes to help him but kelsey grammer
tries to stop them until prime steps in
and Down Goes Frazier
all of them finally kill lockdown yeah
eight is finally cool with Shane the
dinosaur transformers conveniently just
like run off into the bushes and Optimus
takes the seed and flies away to meet
his maker but don't worry
Galvatron / Megatron or whatever the
heck he is somehow has escaped all of
this on the harm in order to set up yet
another Transformers Prime
and that my friends is all you need to
know probably way more than you need to
go to be honest so what's your favorite
transformer movie so far what's your
least favorite did we leave out any
moments let us know in the comments
section below we want to know I want to
thank you for watching I'm Hal Rudnick
hit me up on Twitter by bison
[Music]